thanks for being with me how are you
doing with parenting 24/7 I feel like
that's been kind of a struggle for
everybody well Sasha is I've been taking
on most of the parenting duties while
I'm working from home he is watching the
baby because I have to be on the phone
be in meetings like this and answer
people's questions so I have to hide out
in her room alive
okay well Sasha that is a little bit
contradictory to what we first saw you
conveying that you are ready for on the
show what's it like for you well while
we're staying at home and some of us
should work because I'm not be able to
work because all gyms are closed and I'm
only one who can take care of babies so
that's what I'm doing I'm a babysitter
again how has it been two quarantines
together for your relationship it has
it's good moments definitely and it has
it's bad you know at the end of the day
when work is dying it we spend time
together we these we are like acting
silly being a little crazy because we're
stuck here is crazy but of course that
I'm trying to get things done or trying
to work on a project I have a meeting
coming up and like Sasha you gotta take
him
he's coming mom well your family I don't
know if you're we saw your sister a lot
on the show and she had a lot to say
about you guys's relationship are you
quarantine with any other family members
or is it just the three of you um we are
we are quarantine eing with my dad and
my stepmom and my little if sister um my
dad is older so he's been pretty much
keeping to his room because we have to
go out and yeah we don't want to expose
him to anything my stepmom works in a
hospital so she's gone a lot and my
littlest sister locks herself in her
room to do her online schooling so so
how does from time to time by we're kind
of honor how does the family feel about
you guys's relationship now has their
view of it gotten any better if they had
issues with it before yeah I mean it's
gotten a lot better
my sister is seeing how Sasha interacts
with the baby she's you know she
approves so she likes she likes seeing
that so now she actually um reaches out
to Sasha she needs some update on our
life he is way better at giving than me
Wow
so Sasha have you guys gotten closer
would you say you have a good
relationship now well science we got
here and why while we are living
separate we don't have any problems
because we're nothing to argue about and
the second thing when she visit us in
Christmas we stayed for a week together
and our relationship science Christmas
became better yeah we improve and we're
getting a lot better
nothing ended up in the absolutely not
yeah as I said we're living separated
nothing to discuss and argue about so
maybe that's problem it's not easy to
live with people you know
it doesn't really feel like Sasha's
moving right now he's taking a couple
shirts a couple pairs of shorts oh he's
barely packing anything and it's
worrying me because I don't know what's
going on in his brain right now like is
he fully committed to this what would
you say to those people who conveyed one
of the biggest criticisms about you
which was that they said you were just
using Emily to come to the u.s. um I
understand people who is who was
thinking about me like that that's I
have two marriages and two kids and I
divorced twice and now I'm with Emily
and we got we have a baby and we're
going to Americans
I mean I understand people who thinking
like that because many people are
thinking like that throw their
experience and it's just their opinion
I'm okay with that I don't judge anyone
I I mean what can I change well would
you tell them no I didn't do that
hmm usually I mean if I answer them
usually I said don't judge people for
their pause because you know you don't
know you're talking about using me and
it comes from there I'm asking you you
know in Sasha I'll just ask you I'll
make it I because of the language
barrier think I'll make it clear on the
record marry Emily just to come to the
u.s. of course not I was always actually
honest and truly asked you guys because
I actually felt like we didn't see this
and I wanted to know what do you love
about each other what qualities made you
fall in love with each other we saw a
lot of discourse between you two and I'm
just kind of wondering Emily what made
you fall for Sasha and Sasha what about
Emily's personality made you fall for
her a lot of people don't know so it's
just hilarious kind of like his direct
dry humor like he's so funny to talk to
he's always honest you always know where
you stand with him and he is genuinely a
caring person he cares so much about his
family in Russia he cares about us he
wants to provide he wants to advance
their opportunities for the future he is
on the phone with his mom his sons every
day talking to them keeping contact it's
just really me it's really amazing to
see such honesty and such you know
genuineness it's refreshing actually
so that's what I love the most about
Sasha
Sasha what about you what made you
follow me
well generally emily is beautiful and
kind and she's smart which is really
important
she's intelligent she's really
supportive she respectful which is a
really good quality and I don't know
there's nothing bad about her
nothing and yeah she understand me so
well whatever I'm doing
she's always supporting me that's that's
great and she's kind we never had any
arguments yeah this is just a little
things which is normal well a lot of
people are saying we are physically and
mentally just feed each other thing that
will get a lot of quarantine babies out
of all of this cuz people are spending
so much time together will you guys help
maybe no I made sure that would why do
you say that why I made sure when it
happened and you Sasha said you're not
ready oh well we just got one growing we
need to grow up first we need to get our
own place
we need to I don't know we need to get
some our goals to be more I I don't to
be more financially stable initial was
there bread to make sure we can ever one
little baby without more kids in the
long run do you plan to have more kids
eventually for a few years
okay Monday's to TLC quality time is
never easy
but we're getting because you know you
guys have shared your life on television
and you've been through living in Russia
moving to the u.s. going on TV now
there's a global pandemic it's a lot of
ups and downs
yeah and I'm just wondering honestly how
is your relationship right now are you
struggling are you stronger than ever
are you is it dated what what is your
connection like right now because we're
gonna see a lot of it on the upcoming
special I would say our relationship is
absolutely strong relationships it's
becoming stronger and stronger every day
we got special now we are spending a lot
of time together
that's a great chance to know more
details about details about each other
over those small annoyances that you
encounter like living with someone you
know 24/7 and you know not hold on to
any anger and appreciate them for what
they do then your love gets stronger
absolutely right I think that this is
all more evidence that people love
watching you guys and they are gonna
love watching you on this special what
can you tease about what fans will see
on the upcoming special well they'll see
a lot of cute babies they'll see you
Sasha play with the baby and they'll see
me working and dealing with you know
having the family here I hope that
they'll see more of the silliness
between us and more smiles more
happiness so wait Sasha I just thought
of a way okay
you have only sons now right if you had
another baby and it was a daughter
should your daughter and your son have
all the same opportunities to be able to
get the same education have the same
type of job that that absolutely he's a
feminist oh my god III thought feminists
the means I'm thinking that some man is
a top than woman
well now we know all right so they're
gonna see your silly your side I'm
really in but honestly meeting honestly
I don't want honestly but I'll explain
because the girls are really complicated
you have to buy more for her and when
she'll be teen I'll be worrying so much
I'll be staring her I'll be watching her
all the time I'll be keep her boyfriends
SS to make sure he is the worst net1 I
mean that's really complicated and it's
easier with a boy I and a boy you can
you can yeah most sensitive it's total
different people living with my 15 year
old sister so he seems them hormone I'll
tell you right now I would not want to
be the boy that your daughter brought
home no I would not want to face you but
evident by different way if we'll have a
girl she will have three brothers yeah
which they can take care of her to make
sure stuff yeah if we'll have a girl I
will not be worrying so much
I have three boys so I know we'll take
care of her I love it guys we do not I
have to let you go but I can't wait to
watch you the special
[Music]